in your which brings us if i may to one
of my favorite books your 2000 book this
is a beat up old copy
this book conflict of vision yes which
you published in 2007 and you lay out
i'm sorry 1987. i beg your pardon nice
reprinted in 2007.
well beat up as this book is it turns
out this is the reprint sorry 1987
and you lay out two
competing ways of looking at economics
and politics really two competing ways
of looking at life that go back at least
200 years
the constrained vision
and the unconstrained vision
the constrained vision i'm quoting from
a conflict of visions sees the evils of
the world as deriving
from the limited and unhappy choices
available
given the inherent moral and
intellectual limitations
of human beings close quote
so the constrained vision under itself
understands itself as constrained
by the limitations of reality itself yes
is that yeah that's correct yes okay
in other words they cannot proceed as so
many do that good things happen
automatically but bad things are
somebody's fault
got it
for that if someone has a constrained
vision do you think that they can
change their vision i don't know if
that's something that he talks about is
how you can go from like a constrained
vision to
seeing things
non-constrained
yeah i mean some people switch like
people
because
i think no guys i'm not
i could be butchering this but from my
understanding it's like it's kind of
like when you hear people
talking about how everything's the
world's fault okay so that's like
basically a constrained vision is saying
like the world is the cause of my
problems
okay so it's kind of like not taking
like
accountability yeah so it's like me
saying oh i'm a girl
i can't like all these bad things happen
to me because i'm a girl okay and this
this this i think guys correct me in the
comments if i'm wrong but that's i'm
pretty sure
that's interesting because
it
it's interesting because
there's people that live their life like
that like oh i can't do this this and
this because
i am
whoever i am
but
you shouldn't put yourself into
a box and like i can't do this because
it's like no you can it's just gonna be
harder there's going to be restraints
because
of whatever situation you're in if
you're
if you're going into more so a
male-dominated company or male-dominated
area and you're a woman is going to be
harder and vice versa and if you
look different if you're different
ethnicity and this and third and you
haven't nobody's been in that sector of
whatever it is it's going to be harder
because either you're the first to do or
you're
in a bracket where not a lot of people
have done it but just to be like i can't
do it
because i'm this it's like you're not
even trying it's just you're you're
already giving up before you even give
yourself a chance well and you know what
i've noticed the people that do break
barriers and those sort of things they
never really bring it up
because they don't look at themselves
like like through that lens and it's
interesting because an example i thought
of is when we did that show we were
talking about consumer debt
you remember when we we did that live
show
and they were like oh the reason women
have bad credit is because we just want
to look like better it's society all
this stuff but instead of just saying no
we spend too much and make poor buying
choices you're upset yes like that's
that's from the world view versus like
an individualistic view okay gotcha that
does make sense it's like you're
you're pointing
the blame somewhere else instead of kind
of taking responsibility for your
actions
okay
got it and then to continue here the
constrained vision
again
quoting from a conflict of visions
for the amelioration
improvement of the human condition the
constrained vision relies on
certain social processes such as moral
traditions the marketplace or families
not government
so explain that
why why do we rely why do we rely on
so oh shoot okay one is looking at the
government for the solution okay one is
worth looking at family for a solution
okay so do we kind of like swap those
no it's like it's the same sort of thing
so they would say okay then women need
special grants
because it's looking for two
different actions for solutions yeah oh
so it's like it kind of goes with the
world view though because on like one
hand like back with the consumer debt
like decision they would say oh so girls
need higher credit abilities so we need
this from we need more bailouts from the
government or the right where the other
side would say oh you spent that money
it's your own damn fault and like go to
your family go to your go to your family
for help with that stuff don't don't go
to the government
okay that makes sense yes that does make
sense
on processes
rather than the will of the people
instituting changes to improve our
condition
well
it doesn't ignore government
even for the market the work you have to
have a government as uh
europe discovered when the roman empire
collapsed and the economy has collapsed
also
but i guess
one of the reasons would be that with
the government you have surrogate
decision makers and they cannot possibly
know as much as the individuals whose
personal decisions have been preempted
i see
i will agree with that
wholeheartedly um something that
i just was in discussion with with like
friends and family during this
um
last election or
electing voting people into the office
and all that good stuff
was how can
someone
make a law for
um like low-income people when they
don't understand what it is to be in
that situation
and
it's kind of like if you
if you don't know the situation you can
empathize with someone but you're not
going to physically understand what it
is to be
in
a certain situation whatever it is
and so that was just like
part of the conversation i had and it's
hard to be able to
be like okay yeah i understand when you
may
you may emotionally understand what it
is to be in like a harsh situation but
mentally and physically
if you've never been in it you're never
going to
fully understand it
is there a law you were talking about i
cannot remember off the top of my head
it was it was just like amidst um
election time and
it was talking about the people that we
were electing i
can't remember okay i was just wondering
if it was like a specific law if i
remember that i'll be like yeah it was
this right now my brain's like
i see all right which brings us to the
unconstrained vision
when again i'm quoting you when rousseau
said that man is born free but
everywhere in chains
he expressed the essence of the
unconstrained vision which the in which
the fundamental problem is not nature
or man but institutions yes would you
explain that one well he has the notion
that again that that good things happen
naturally
and there are bad things it's because
institutions including civilization
itself have made these bad things happen
and of course